よろしくお願いします
で あの 直接始まりますけど
どこまで行ったか覚えてないんですが
じゃあ百八十三ページの十七番目のこの十七番目の十八番目の問識非問識というドワールーパ・アドワールーパというところ
で そこら辺はそんなに難しくはないんだけど
アビダンマは詳しく勉強する場合は
このたまにこの用語が必要になりますから
そこら辺でこの基本的な用語を説明してるだけなんです
で この識という物質の世界
物質的なエネルギーのことを説明してきて
それはまあいろんなこのグループに分けてみるんです
ただそれだけ それは何の役に立ちますか？と
それはこの普通の人々の知識には別に関係ないかもしれませんだけど
この あの 仏教で仰ってるこの心理の世界を理解する場合は大変必要な知識にもなります
で で 門というのはあのドワールで門と書いているんですね
そこで何が門というと
この 認識 我々生きてるものはいろんなものを生きてるということは認識しているんですね
ものは知ってるということは生きてるということ
何も知らないということは
まあ生きてるものではなくなっちゃうんです
ですから もう大変わかりやすい区別で
生命と生命でないものはどうやって区別しますか？と言えば
生命には外の世界は認識できる
生命でない物体には外の世界の存在は認識できませんと
その二つの分け方なんですね
ですから この 例えば一般的な人間の考え方を見れば
人間には魂はあるんだけど
動物にはないはないかとか
あるいは人間を殺してはいけませんだけど
動物は殺しても構いませんではないかというふうな
この世の中のこの一般的ないろんな考え方がありますね
世の中で昔から今まで
で そういう風に立場は仏教でないんですね
人間に魂があります 動物に魂がないんですよという場合は
人間のどこが魂かと説明しなくちゃいけないし
それは動物にはないという証拠も必要であるし
そういう証拠がないんだから
仏教ではそんなことは取り扱わない
考えない その代わりに
生命と生命でないものは何でしょうかと言えば
建物やら机やら椅子やら
そういうものは生命でないということはわかる
なぜかというと それは外の世界は認識しない
外の世界を認識するならば
それは生命であると そういう点で見ると
我々は仏教の世界ではその点で生命を区別しているんだから
生命を平等に考えているんですね
虫でも誰でも構いませんし
微生物でもしょうがないし
外の世界を認識しているならば
それはちゃんとした生命になるんですね
人間であろうが虫であろうがどうしようもないんですね
どっちでも外の世界認識しているんだから
そういうことで 仏教では生命という概念が使ってあって
人間を殺してはいけませんだけど
動物を殺しては正しい
殺しても構いませんというふうなことは言わないんです
人間でないんだからいいんじゃないかというふうな
まあそれすごい力強い考え方なんですけど
世の中に 仏教はそういうことはないんです
ただ区別するのは認識のこと
ですから この認識という働きをとても大事に考えて
このいろんな枠を カテゴリーを作っているんです
今日は問識と非問識という 2つの分け方
問というのは認識の問なんですね
いわゆる認識できる 認識するためには情報を体にあるいは心に触れなくちゃいけないんですね
では 情報を触れるところ
そこは問というんですね
ただそれだけ そこでこの五情識というパンチパサーダというこの情識
5つありますね それはよくもう何回も言ってますから
この覚えられるまで何回何回も言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
チャップソタカーンディゥハーカーヤというパーリ語で言えばその 5つなんですね
眼耳鼻舌身という 5つなんですね
そういう 5つの識が働きがありまして
そこから我々は色声香味触という 5つのエネルギーを体験するんです
そこにそのエネルギーは触れちゃう
触れ 触れたところで心がそれを認識する
ですから その 5つの識が問識なんですね
それは門であってドゥアラなんです
で もう二つこっちに付け加えているんです
あの でヴィンニャッティという
ヴィンニャッティ色二つ
それはカーヴィンニャッティ
ワチーヴィンニャッティ
標識ですか 標識ですか
外標識と  身標識という二つの標識
標識って言ったらなんかわけのわからない言葉かもしれませんだけど
これはこの あの なんですかね
表現という意味なんですね
表現する方法なんですね
標識っていうのは で 例えば私は何か人に表現してあげたい
何か人に言いたい 表現したい
その場合 私は二つの方法を使うんですね
一つは体を使って表現する
もう一つは言葉で表現する
他の表現方法はないんです
ですから 私は例えば体を使って
もう怒ってる顔をしたり
あるいは泣いてる顔をしたり
あるいは笑っ 笑ってる顔をしたりすると
それは体のいろんな表情なんですね
あるいは踊ったり いろんなことをしたり
それは身標識と言うんです
そこら辺で誤解しやすいんだから
この標識 僕は色勉強教えるんだけど
まあある人々はヒンドゥー教で大乗仏教で言ってるような
この実体論で考えてるようには感じますけど
それ仏教は絶対実体論ではないんだから
ただエネルギーのことを言ってますからね
まあそこら辺間違ったら私は別にまあ何も責任持ちませんだけど
混乱するのはまあ実体論考えてる人々だけですけど
とにかくこの身標識 体で表すこと
例えば手を振る 手を振ることによって人にこっちいらっしゃい
ここから出て行きなさいと
あるいは違いますよと
そうですよということが手を振ることから言えるんですね
それはなんで特別な色として
物質として考えてるんですかと
おかしいではないかと思うかもしれません
おかしくも何にもないんで
それは それは私は体を持って人に物事を表現している
そうすると私の体から何かエネルギーが出るんです
そのエネルギーはその人に伝わるんです
何かのチャンネルを通して
ですから 単なるエネルギーの動きですから
ある一種のエネルギーの動きであって
それは身標識と呼んで
それで体で物事を表すことはできます
次に 言葉で 音で物事を表現することができます
ですから この標識二つ
カーヴィンニャッティ
ワチーヴィンニャッティ
体を持って人に知らせする
知らせる 言葉を持って人に物事を知らせるという二つの働きにも色と物質というんです
その七つは門識というんです
と言うんだけど まあそちらへもうちょっと問題がありますけど
門というのは入る 情報入るところですから
まあちょっと考えると
この表識二つは情報が入るところじゃなくて
情報発生するところなんです
ですからどうかなと思いますけど
まあこちらはそういうふうに入れてるんですね
ですから 五法識は あ 五常識は
パータ・ドゥーパとチャックソータ・ガミ・ワカーヤっていうのは外から情報を受け取る場所なんです
ですから門というのはわかります
自分の体から人に何か伝える場合は
こちらから外へ出ているものだから
まあそこをなんで門識にしているかっていうことは
まあちょっとわかりません
ですから 七つは門識で
二十一種類はあの非門識になるんです
次の二つの分け方 インリヤ・ルーパ
アニンリヤ・ルーパ で
インリヤはこのテキストで
この百八十四ページでページの十九番目ですけど
根識と解釈していますけど
インリヤには違う言葉も
うんうん そこでこの識はまた二つに分けて見ることができます
インドリヤ識とアニンドリヤ識と分けることはできるんです
インドリヤ・ルーパ アニンドリヤ・ルーパ
インドリヤっていうのは
大体この働く場所というふうな意味なんですね
事務所みたいなところなんです
だから事務所といえば事務をやるところなんですね
場所がなければ事務できませんし
そういうふうなこの意味でインドリヤ faculty
と言うんですね 英語だったら
ですから 何かをする まあ場所 institution
みたいな facultyなんですけど
まあ何か仕事をする場所なんですね
そこで識 物質のエネルギーが一部がこの仕事をする場所を通してあって
もう一部がそうではないと
こちらで何の仕事をというと
わかりやすく認識の仕事
他のの何の関係もないんです
だから生命の働きといえば認識することだけなんです
それはよく理解してください
いわゆる普通の世界では
いろんな働きがあるのではないか
いろんな仕事を人間にあるんではないかと
動物にもそれなりに仕事があるんではないかとか
そういうのはまあ 側論であって
例えば子供を産むことやら
子供を育てることやら
縄張りを作ることやら
餌を探すことやら そういうのはもう側世間の仕事であって
極端的に考えると生命っていうのは認識する機能なんですね
ですから 生命の唯一の仕事は物事を認識することだけ
ですから 生命の仕事は何ですかというと
認識すること 認識といえば
妄想することも認識であって
寒いと思うことも認識であって
働く歩くことも認識でありまして
すべては認識することによって成り立っているんであって
ですから 自分が生命であると
尊い命であるという そんな余計なおろかなものを考えないで
単なるなぜ私は生命であって生きる生きてるものでありますかで
座って瞑想でよくわかるんだから
足が痛くなるわ あっちしびれるわ
腰が痛いし いろんなこと出てくるでしょうに
瞑想していると そういう痛みがないと眠くが眠くなってくるし
そうでないといろんな妄想が生まれてくるし
もう瞑想していてもあまりうまくいかないとか
いろいろあるし そこで
だからヴィパッサナーでは瞑想うまくいってるかないかあまり気にしないんですね
なぜ気にしないというと
例えばずっと妄想していたっても
それを知っていれば それは生命であって
何かを認識することは生命であると
大したことはないんだと
そこに あなたあなたあなたと言うんだけど
私私と言うんだけど ろくなものではないんだ
ただの認識だけですと
物質的なもところがあって
そこに認識という働きが動いて
ですから それは妄想であろうが
行動な戦場であろうが
サマーディであろうが
まあどうったことないんです
ただ認識しているだけ
ですから 生命の働きは認識である
そこでfacultyといえば
インドリヤといえば仕事なんです
仕事といえば何ですかというと
認識することなんです
だから仕事をする識は仏教は何ですかと聞かれると
わかりやすいことで あのなんてチャックソートガーナジワーカーという５つになるんですね
そこで５つ パサドルーパ
常識 常識というのは眼耳鼻舌身ですね
目と耳と鼻と舌と体の働きですね
目そのものではなくて
目の働き 眼であって 耳の働きは耳と呼んで耳と呼ぶんですね
鼻の働きは鼻といって
だから眼耳鼻舌身 その 5つの働きあって
そこで認識の仕事をする
あるいは聴覚という仕事は
耳という事務所で行っているということなんですね
視覚するという仕事は
目という事務所でやっているんですね
感覚 観測という体で触れて感じるということは
体という皮膚という事務所でもやっているのです
そこがなければ その仕事はできなくなっちゃうんです
そこで 5つが出てくるのです
なんですか 次にバーバルーパ
バーバルーパとは性ですね
男性女性と書いてありましたから
この性別の 性別 性別する働き
男性か女性かと この性別する働きも
この体の中のある一つのエネルギーなんですね
それも認識に関わりがあるんだと
あるいはまあ男色というこの生殖ですね
男の生殖という働きがあると
その生命は男性として認識の方向性を変えちゃう
イッキバーバルーパという女性になる生殖が生まれたら
その生命が女性として自分の認識方向性を変えてしまうと
それは動物見たっても同じことなんですね
オスとメスの場合は オスになる式が生まれたらオスとして仕事をしたり
メスとして式が生まれたらそういうふうに仕事をしていて
認識方向性それによって変えてしまっちゃうんですね
そういうことで このインディールーパという場合は
本質というんですか の場合はこの生殖 2つも考え
数えられるんですね いわゆる働き場所ですからね
例えばある生命は男にするという場合は
その体の中であるエネルギーが働いているんですね
そのエネルギーがなければ
その生命は男にならない
あるいは女性にはならないんですね
もしそれ抜けちゃったら
男でも男性でも 女性でも亡くなっちゃうんです
そこでインドルーパ七つになります
次にジーヴィトルーパかな
ジーヴィタ ジーヴィトルーパ
命 命識 あの命識っていうのは命という字書いて識と書くんですね
命というのはこの まあ物質にもう大変まあ分かりにくいエネルギーなんですけど
まあいわゆる まあ壊れないで
まあなんとなくまあエネルギーとして続けるんですね
その続けられることは命というんですね
いわゆるエネルギーを支えられていて
まあジーヴィテインディリ
だから物質にもジーヴィタ
物質にはジーヴィテインディリ
命という働きまたあります
その命という言葉使ってますけど
ジーヴィタという言葉使ってますけど
それはもう魂とか霊魂とかいう風な概念でとるとる必要はないんです
で まあ明確に言えばといえば
この我々はこのものを見たら
物質見たっても そこに命があるかないかということはもうもういとも簡単に分かりますからね
例えば植物一つ取ってきて
取ってきただけでその植物は死ぬわけじゃないんです
そこではまだ生きていると分かってるんですね
それで植物はそれをまた植え替えないで
そのまま放っておけば
一日 二日 三日になると
もうただの物質になってしまっちゃうんですね
徐々に その場合はあるエネルギーは消えていくんですね
その消えてるエネルギーはまあ命識というものなんですね
生命の生きるものの場合はもっと早いんだからね
命がなくなっちゃったら
死んじゃったらすぐ死んだ死体はもう物質に変わってるんですね
植物より早いんです 早いというか
早くないかもしれません
だけど植物は死ぬのは遅いというかね
我々は酸素がなくなっちゃったらすぐ死んでしまっちゃうんだけど
植物はそうじゃないんですね
酸素なくなった途端いきなり死んでしまうということはなくて
死ぬためには時間がかかるだけのことで
生命の場合はすぐ死んでしまっちゃう
でも植物もまあ熱には弱い
例えば 外から拾ってきた植物は
家の中で植え替えなくても
一ヶ月とかでも持ちますよと思っても
それはお湯なんかに入れてみたら
もうすぐ死んでしまっちゃうんです
また いくら鉢に植えてももう生えないんですね
芽が出ませんだから 熱には弱い
すぐ死ぬ そうでないとそんな早く死なない
まあとりあえずその命というエネルギーなんですね
この命識というのは まあまあ前説明しましたから
まあもういちいち説明いりませんと思いますけど
忘れちゃったら私は困りますから
進めな 続けなく 進めなくなっちゃうんです
で その八種類の識 五浄識と二つの生識と命識という八種類はインドリエルーパと言うんです
残り二重はアニンドリエルーパと言うんです
だからなんでそんなに分けますかというと
やっぱり認識することが大事なんですね
生命としては そこでこの体で我々はどこらへんに基づいて認識していますかということも大事なんです
それすっごく大事なの
なぜかというと 仏教ではこのほかの人々は宗教も哲学も喋ってますけど
物事わかってないという批判があるんですね
例えば わかりやすく言えば
日本では人が亡くなったらもう骨に対する執着というと並のものじゃないんです
生きている場合は殺してやりたいほど怒ってるんだけど
その人死んじゃったらもう火葬して
それで骨だけ大事に大事に話しかけるんですね
骨に あれ 何の根拠もない
骨は魂であるわけでもないし
何もないんですね 潰してしまえばそれで終わっちゃうし
何かね もう植木鉢に花でも何か植えるのにそこに入れちゃえばいい
もう肥料になるのに それは絶対しない
している そこにもし悪口言ったらものすごくもう大変な反感
でしょ もし私が今言った言葉
日本の寺のお坊さんでも言っちゃったらもう暗殺されるかもしれない
信者さんに それぐらい骨に対するすごい執着あるんです
あれ何ですかと聞くと
別に訳あるわけじゃなくて
まあずっとそういう風に考えてるだけのこと
そこで仏教ではまあそういうのはまあ何の意味もないことだと言うんですね
ある日本の文化を勉強する学者が
もしかすると一生懸命哲学作るかもしれません
骨はいかに大事かということについては
お墓の歴史やら まあもうああだこうだとか
本まで書くかもしれません
遠い昔から人間はお墓作ったと
そこでちゃんと人を埋めておいたと
例えばもういろんな発掘しちゃうと
やっぱり人間の骨が出てくるんではないかと
ですから 肉体は滅びても骨だけ滅びないのではないかと
いくらでも理屈は言えるんだけど
そういうのは全部単なるもう頭のからくりというか
頭の空回りだけであって意味がない
そこでまたどこに魂があるんですかと
体の中でヒンドゥー教でもよく考えたんですね
ヒンドゥーの世界ではこの心臓に魂があるんだと一応決着つけたんです
そこで何がわかって心臓に魂があるんだと決着つけたんですかね
何にも証拠ないんです
ただまあそうですよ どこか誰かが言ったんだから
例えばウパニシャッドなんかに書いてるんですね
ウパニシャッドに心臓に魂が宿ってるんだと書いてるんだから
ああ それは何とか何とかウパニシャッドにあるんだから
まあそれはその通りですよ
そこでみんな信じちまっちゃうんです
誰一人もブリアダーラナウパニシャッド書いたあの仙人ももう何のことなく
ただのバカの一人でよとは言わないんです
その人はバカではないかと考えないんです
やっぱりそういうウパニシャッドにこう書いてるんだから
それでですか 心臓にの中に魂があるんだ
そこで魂の大きさはこの親指ぐらいだと
と言ったりして まあそこでもうそんなことはないんだから
まあそれはやっぱり瞑想しなきゃわからないんです
言っちゃったら まあそれで話は終わりと
瞑想する人は瞑想で私は瞑想したんだけど
心臓の中に親指ぐらいの魂はあることをわからなかった
あなたの瞑想はダメですよって言っちゃえば
まあそれで それで終わりですね
話は ですから この人間っていうのは
この 自分の体に対していろんな変な理念を持ってるんですね
体全体全部大事ですよとか
あるいは心臓だけ大事ですよと
あるいは 骨だけ大事ですよとか何とか思ったりする可能性あるし
そこで仏教はそんなことはそんな簡単に批判するっていうことではなくて
この体の中 体を構成されている物質の中で
一部の物質を中心にして我々は認識しているんだと
もう一部の物質は別に気にしないんだと
それで魂論 私という実感が生まれるならば
この認識の働きをやらせている物質の方が見た方がいいのです
ですから インドリルーパ
インドリルーパ ドワールルーパ
ドワールルーパということにちゃんと分けておくんです
その分け方は この大変なこの哲学的なこのことを理解するために
もう基本的にやってるものなんです
そこでもし我々に この例えば性色
性色 性 性 性 区別する色というエネルギーがありますよと
それはただのもう一つのエネルギーと同じものであると分かったところで
自分がこの男性であって
ですから魂は男性ですよと
私は女性だから元々魂は女性で
そんな話はもう言わなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ不思議なこと 宗教は魂はあると言うんだけど
魂は何 性別とは言えないんですね
そこまで考える暇がないでしょうと思いますけどね
人間に性別あるんだから魂に性別があるはずなんですけどね
そこはまだ考えてない
で あるいはまあ性別なし
このニュートロジェンダーですか
この男性名詞でもなく中性名詞で使ったりはしているんですね
で そんなことっていうのはもう単なる推測だけであって
ですからこの性色を分かったら
なるほど こういうエネルギーで私は男で
この人は女ですよと 分かってしまう
で 何か見て驚いて感動しましたならば
あ それは別に魂が感動してるわけじゃなくて
目から入った情報について自分の認識が刺激しているんだと
驚いてるんだとわかるんですよね
そうわかると 例えば人がそのよくあるんです
この夕焼けとか この富士山に乗ってみたところとかね
富士山に乗って朝日の出なんか見たら
まあみんなものすごい声して
もう合唱して もう涙ボロボロ
その辺で僕なんて お前ら何やってるんですか？と
バカではないかと言っちゃったら
もう なんて言いますか
インシュアランス ライフインシュアランスでもしておいた方がいいんです
落とされるかもしれません
やっぱりたった富士山に登ったところ
やっぱり日本人になってよかったと
こういう堂々たるもう感動は日本人にしか誰もわからない
とか そういうとこまで行っちゃうんですね
ですから そこに宗教あるわけじゃないし
富士山の上にもやっぱりちゃんと神社があるんだけどね
でまあ富士山あれ個人のものだそうですね
国のものじゃなくて あれ神社の神社あれいるんです
で まあどうでもいいんだけど
そこに何かあるわけじゃなくて
やっぱり高い山に登ったところで視界がものすごく大きくなるんですね
ですから 普通に見えるより先に日の出が見えるんです
我々はもう七時半 八時半で起きて
空見たってもう太陽見えませんんだから
建物ばっかしで そこでこの
太陽が現れる前からもう光だけ見えてきて
これはすっごいもう感動する
美しい見物なんですね
ものすごい なんて言いますかね
すごい綺麗なビジョンなんですね
ですから それを見ると
もう体中誰でも私でも感動するんです
なんかちらちらとすごく光が出てきて
この地球も振動しながら回ってますから
スムーズに回ってるわけじゃないんです
振動して もう磁石みたいに引っ張られてるでしょ
ですから こうやって回るんじゃなくて
このこうこうこう こう時計の歯車が回るような感じで
このチクチクしながら回ってるんですね
ですから それを太陽の光を見てると見えるんです
そこで見ているとすごく感動する
で 仏教でない人は そのあまりにも体中広げたこの感動の光
強烈さに惹かれて もういきなり宗教的な
あるいはまあなんとか感情をそそってしまいます
ですから仏教ではこの目のことを覚えておきなさい
そこでただ目があって
そこに何か光があって
それは入って 自分の認識
働きが刺激しているんだ
喜びを感じている そこに他の何もないんだと
ということで違う智慧を得られるんですね
そういうことで 世の中で一般の俗論として言ってる
まあ宗教やら哲学やら概念やらいろんな迷信やら
そういうものからいきなり自分が解放してもらうんです
そういうふうに分解して物事を見ると
そのためにそういう区別ですか
必要なんです インドリルーパ
アニンドリルーパは何であろうかと
ある まあ例えば過去世で悪いことをしたんだから女性で生まれたんだとか
過去世でいいことをしたんだだから男で生まれたんだとか
よく言ってるでしょうに
そんなものを真に受けて
それに哲学作る人々もいるし
何のこともないんです
ただ体付いたところで
性別するエネルギーは女性の識が入っちゃったんだから女性になったんであって
男性の識が入っちゃったんだから男性になってるだけのことです
そこに尊いものでも何もないんです
女性は不浄だからどこか道が入ってはいけませんとか
あるいは男性は宗教やってるところは
女性が宗教やってるときは男性は入ってはいけませんとか
たまにある文化ではこのあの処女と読むんですか
少女と読むんですか？このあの
そういう女の子たちを神様に立てますって
それからまあ結婚する年になってくると
もう神の座からもう外れちゃう
もうあんたはもう過去の神であって
もう今は神じゃない人間ですよと
そういうふうな あの そういう女の子たちっていうのは
もう神様になっちゃいますから
すっごいもう贅沢させてもらうんですね
まあ顔を洗ってもらうわ
もう食べさせてもらうわ
もういつでもこの 結局大きくなったら結婚したくなるでしょ
それでもし男性に気が行っちゃったら
もうあんたはこの日に限って
もう神ではないといきなりもう一般の女の子にしちゃうんですね
だから最悪なんですね
何も自分でできないんだから
ですから もう天と地獄
両方ように で そこで私たちは仏教から言うのはそんなもう何のこともないんですと
ただ 正式はああいう風になったんだから
女性であって男性であるだけのことですと
そういうふうな この理解のために
そういうもう そんなことを言っちゃったら
みんな偉そうに そうです
そんなこと何意味がないんだと偉そうなことを言うかもしれませんだけど
あんなものはもう失礼なんです
これとことん理解したところで意味のないということは分かってほしいんです
何のことを理解もしないで
例えばもう日本人がね
富士山を信仰するっていうことをバカにしてはいけないんです
何がわかる それバカにしてるもんですかと
それは見てもいない そうじゃなくて
もっと 行動のレベルで物質の働き
心の働きを理解してたところで
そういうものは意味がないと
理解してても構いませんだけど
ですから この片っ端から人の神経やら鉄緑やらね
もう壊す 壊してしまえということじゃなく
じゃなくて理解しておきましょうと
そこでまあ もうなんとなく仏教の言葉を一つ二つ耳に入っただけで
偉そうなことを言う中に言って歩くまわる人々いるんだけど
ああいうのは迷惑であって
お釈迦様はそういうふうな失礼なことを言うわけじゃないんです
きちんと理解してたところで
落ち着いて考えて喋ればいいんです
その話で まあ一応こういう分け方出てくるんです
で じゃあこれから早く行きましょう
オーラーリカルーパーディ
スクムルーパーディ  言うべきかは分かりましたよね
また二つ二つに分けるんです
オーラーリカルーパ この漢字はどういうふうに読みますかね
この ん？粗？うん 粗識と細識
で 二つ二つに分ける 粗識
あ 粗い識と まあ細かい識と
いわゆるエネルギーの波動が
もう大きい識と波動が小さい識というふうに分けられちゃうし
それから近色遠色と 近い識と遠い識と
有色と 有体色と無体色と
こっちのセットはそういう三つあるんですね
言葉三つ あのセットは三つであって
分け方はなんです 例えば粗識
近色 有体色は同じものなんです
細色 遠色 無体色っていうのはまた同じもので
何でしょうかね そういう粗っぽい色っていうのは
常識と共識ですね 常識は五つですし
あの 眼耳鼻舌身だから
えっと 共識っていうのは色声味触というもので
そこで十二なんです 全部種類としては
そういうのはもの前説明しましたからね
見ればわかると思います
常識は五つで 共識はカテゴリーとしては五つですけど
中身は七つなんですね
ですから十二になるんです
いわゆるチャック 目は一つで
目に入る識は まあ一つで色だけですから
耳は一つで耳に入る音はまた一そこで四つであって
舌と味はまた二つだけ
二つですから で 鼻と香りはまた二つであるし
で 体の問題は 体に触れるのはパタウィとテージョ
と あ？ワーヨ で まあそこら辺いろいろ
まあ問題あったりなかったりはするんだけど
もうパタウィとテージョとワーヨと三つ体に触れる
だから体に三つ触れる
耳に一つ触れる 鼻に一つ触れる
舌に一つ触れる 目に一つ触れる
触れるものは共識 触れられる世界は常識
触れられる世界は五つで
触れる世界はそれで七つで
でも常識は五つ 共識は五つと僕普通に言うんだけど
そこに十二種類あるんです
その十二種類には粗識とも言うし
近色も言うし なんで粗識は粗っぽい
粗い識と言うんですかね
こういう考え方でしょうね
例えば目がありまして
目には我々目で光を受け取っちゃうんですね
だから目の振動がすごい細かくて
光の信号が粗っぽくなっちゃったら見えなくなっちゃう
目の振動は光を通っていってしまっちゃいますから
やっぱり目の振動が大きくて粗っぽいだから光の振動がぶつかっちゃうんです
耳の方が粗っぽくて音の方が細かいんだと
だから受け取ることはできるんだと
というぐらいの簡単な考え方なんですね
いわゆる受け取る場合は
受け取るものが強くなければ
[笑い]